[Musique]
voilà un air qui devrait éveiller les
souvenirs de ses pensionnaires
et c'est bien la finalité de cette
animation c'est le clarinettiste manioc
sainte-rose et de pianiste josé l'encré
qui sont chargés de créer l'ambiance est
de faire remonter toutes les belles
émotions
des résidents de l'ehpad loisirs tout le
monde ne peut pas se lever pour danser
les ces personnes âgées expriment leur
joie comme elles peuvent alors vous êtes
bien amusé aujourd'hui vous êtes bien
amusé aujourd'hui comme hier mercredi je
suis imaginé deux jours à quesques et de
mercredi rosich et animation musicale à
tous les neurones je chante un petit peu
très très très bien
en principe tout ce que vous voulez
parler comme ça en machin c'est toujours
impeccable et fictive et à chaque fois à
pourquoi parce qu'il ya souvent de la
musique ici la musique d organe ad
après a toujours une histoire
veut pas dire exactement mais je suis
toujours là une dernière journée
organisée sur le thème du lien
intergénérationnel
sauf que les jeunes qui ont répondu à
l'invitation sont restés plutôt discrets
leur implication était à peine
perceptible effet je vous ai pas
beaucoup vu vous amuser avec toutes les
personnes âgées aujourd'hui pourquoi
bah en fait c'est pas qu'on s'amusait
pas c'est que ont préféré qu'ils
s'amusent oeuvres que nous on est encore
jeune on peut s'amuser comme on veut
mais eux c'est bien que aujourd'hui plus
amusée comme une pub avec des amis si ça
vous fait peur de vieillir
oui une semaine de discussions de débats
autour de thèmes d'actualité comme celui
de l'environnement tels les sargasses et
le chlordécone des ateliers manuels pour
stimuler la motricité et la mémoire
histoire de garder les pieds sur terre
une vraie thérapie
on aime ou qu'on a eu ça participe à
leur bien-être c'est une thérapie
oui je pense que oui et puis il faut les
intéresser aussi ce qui se passe autour
de nous on évolue à l'extérieur et c'est
bien de leur rappeler que ce qui se
passe autour d'eux
les problématiques les sargasses
chlordécone tout ça et ils se posent des
questions aussi donc c'est bien d'y
répondre
et bien sûr les résidents se lâche et se
lance même dans un darlas ghaddar tout
le monde s'y donnent à coeur joie
bâle a pris les mêmes les journalistes
ne refuse pas une invitation à danser
[Musique]
on sait si gentiment demandé
rapportée